What's going on? Alan Drau here and in
today's video we are going to be
breaking down Alex Hormos's copywriting
and VSSL secrets, specifically the VSSL
that he's been running millions of
dollars worth of ads to for
acquisition.com.
So on my screen, we're going to dive
right into it. We're going to watch the
VSSL and I'm going to do a live reaction
playback and give you my personal
feedback on what he's doing, how he's
navigating his VSSL, so you could take
away those tips and write better copy,
record better VSSLs, and sell more stuff
using his secrets that he's running
millions of dollars of ads to. So,
really, really good stuff. Let's go
ahead and pivot over here. I'm going to
look at my screen and let's dive right
in. Okay, so this is the acquisition.com
landing page headline. Let's dissect
that really quick before we hit play on
this. First off, I love how it shows
like it's already going like when you uh
when you first start it. This is super
smart. Like it's already running, but
when you hit play, it's going to start
from the beginning. Super smart little
feature there. I love that. Okay, so
says, "Are you the thing limiting your
business?" Now, this some copywriters
would look at this and be like, "Man,
that headline kind of sucks." He stayed
broad on purpose. very clearly he's
going after a broad set of businesses
cuz he's running a lot of different ads
to this. Like, hey, are you a doctor? Do
you own a landscape company? Do you own
a boxing gym? Right? He's got a bunch of
different ad styles running to this. So,
it makes sense that he would go with a
really broad ad that focuses on the
pain. Hey, are you the thing limiting
your business where somebody would say
that and be like, uh, yeah, I I think
so. I think I am. I think I'm the
bottleneck. Join our scaling workshop.
remove yourself as the single point of
failure. Okay, so he's leading with fear
in there. All right. Well, let's watch
the VSSL and let's see what he does.
>> Let me ask you a question. Have you ever
felt like you can't take a vacation
without spending half your time on your
laptop? Or delegating feels super risky
because no one else kind of knows it
like you do and most of the company's
knowledge, you know, exists inside of
your head. Or maybe your team looks to
you for every single answer, even the
tiny ones, and you secretly resent them
for it. Or you
>> Okay, I see what he's doing here. All
right. So, what he's doing is he's
starting with pain. Okay, which totally
makes a lot of sense because people care
more about their pain than your pitch,
right? Nobody wants to be sold to.
Nobody wants to watch a VSSL. Nobody
wants to read ads. They don't want to do
those things. What they actually want to
do is they want to solve a problem. The
reason they click the ad is because they
have a problem and you either had a big
promise or a big uh problem call out in
the ad itself so that they can see that
resonate and be like, "Yes, yes, can you
solve this for me?" And so he's saying
things that people have said to
themselves about them being the problem.
Now, Dan Kennedy once said that if you
can explain someone's problem better to
them than they can say it to themselves,
then you will earn their trust forever.
And I think that's exactly what Alex is
trying to do here, especially with that
line where he's like, "Uh, does it irk
you like when your employees come to you
for every little thing, even the small
ones?" Like that is something that a
true business owner, somebody who's gone
through the trenches, not only
experiences as a pain, but is able to
actually say to someone else because
nobody really says those things out
loud. Those are the quiet things said in
your target audience's brain. And so he
understands his target audience very
clearly and he's actually saying the
things that you can only say if you've
been in there. And so he's actually
digging out the deep deep pains instead
of like the surface level Reddit stuff,
but he's doing it back to back to back
to back to back, right? He just said
three, four, five, six paints. I don't
know how many more he's going to go, but
let's see what he's doing.
>> You worry of what would happen to
revenue if you got sick or disappeared
for a month because all the sales and
fulfillment rely on you. Maybe you just
feel guilty when you're with your family
because you're not working. And you feel
guilty when you're working because
you're not with your family. And if that
sounds at least familiar, you have
something that we call keyman risk.
Okay. So, it looks like he did six or
seven problems. Okay. And then he's
doing like the if then Gary Halper say
statement where he's like and if that
sounds familiar then right and and
that's his transition. Very classic Gary
Halper statement. So, bunch of pain pain
pain
that builds trust. It's like man this
guy really knows what he's talking about
but it seems like he's attacking a lot
of different levels of pain which he's
doing because he's selling to a really
broad set audience. If you were selling
to a niche audience, I'm not sure if I
would be doing six or seven of those. Uh
maybe maybe two, maybe three depending
on your offer. Uh but he he went after
it and it looks like he's about to
introduce either a framework or a
mechanism or something that explains
their pain. Which again, if you can
explain that pain to me better than I
can explain it to myself, I will trust
you forever. Let's see what he does.
>> Which means that you're constantly
working in the business and not on the
business. It's the number one reason why
entrepreneurs can't scale. And it's also
why they can't sell their companies. And
it's also why they feel crap. It's after
hosting over a thousand businesses.
>> Okay. So, what he did was he introduced
he named your problem which makes your
problem significantly easier to
understand because later he's he better
be he better sell a solution to that
problem. But first, he had to name it.
He had to give it a thing, right? And
the easier that you can name a problem,
the easier that you can identify the
problem, the easier you could sell the
solution. So if your problem is not
easily identifiable, if there's not a
name for it, right? Like if you know if
you're selling like something for back
pain, you could easily sell back back
pain pills or anything like that. But
right now he's selling something like
I'm limiting my business. Well, you
can't sell I'm limiting my business, you
know, workshop or something like that.
So he calls it keyman risk. So you have
to name the problem that your target
audience has so it's easily
identifiable. So when you sell them the
solution later, they know what the
solution is for. Now, right here on the
screen, it says he's done this for over
a thousand businesses. So, as he's
agitating the pain, right, which he just
did a second ago, he did a pain
agitation. He did pain, pain, pain, pain
pain, pain pain, and then he agitated
and then you feel trapped and then you
can't sell and then you can't scale. So,
he's agitating that pain to make it hurt
even more. Well, he's like, "Hey, do you
have this pain?" Well, this is what
happens when you don't fix it. very
classic uh problem agitation solution
formula. So, he's he's taking it, but it
looks like he's injecting proof really
early on, right? I've helped over a
thousand businesses do this. If he's
injecting proof this early on, he must
be pivoting to something they're either
not aware of, i.e. they're not solution
aware of the thing he's about to pivot
to, or they don't understand what he's
about to say next. So, let's see. Here
at a headquarters in Vegas over the last
two years, I've noticed one very common
theme that separates entrepreneurs who
scale fast from the one who stays
trapped for a long time. Most of the
owners think that they own a business
when in reality they own a very
expensive highpaying job. And so keyman
risk is when a single person is vital to
the business operating. All right? And
so if they're gone, your business stops
working. And for some this risk shows up
when growth explodes and you know it
feels like the wheels are falling off
the bus. For others, it's, you know,
they're launching a new line and
realizing that they don't have the
systems in order to support it or
they're just starting, you know, to try
and consider an exit only to find out
that the business is actually inselable.
This is something that I went through
and so Keman risk is
>> okay. So, you see how he ended that line
and this is something that I went
through. What he just did was he's
building credibility and trust. This is
almost like instead of actually telling
a story, he's telling different versions
of a story. So typically in a sales
letter you hear a lot of people are like
uh tell you know tell a story like the 4
P framework like picture promise you uh
and picture is the story right you want
to start with a story whatever he
started with pain but he and then he
agitated the pain but then he has to
make himself relative trustworthy he has
to get on the level of the business
owner where he say hey I've been on your
level but I've also accomplished your
level and I'm going to guide you along
with me right I've I've been there. I've
beaten it and I'm going to be your
guide. I'm going to pull you along. And
nothing is more relative than that than
a story. And so what he's basically
doing is he's telling a bunch of
different angles of stories of how this
happens. Hey, when this happens, that's
what happened. And I know because I've
been there and I've been in the trenches
and and that's what happened to me with
my business. So he kind of teed it up
and then threw himself in the loop in
that story. Really smart. I really like
how he did that. Let's see what else he
does. is always painful, but when you're
doubling revenue or adding a new product
line or preparing for a sale, it can
destroy everything that you've built.
And that's when founders realize they
can't keep being the bottleneck. And so,
just look at it like this. Your business
is like a bridge, right? You have a
thousand people on one side and a
thousand people on the other side of the
bridge. But if you are the bridge, the
second you leave, everyone falls in the
water.
>> Okay, this is really, really good. So
whenever whenever you need to explain
something like a new concept like this,
like if your target audience just
learned this keyman risk concept for the
first time, if you're introducing a
framework or like you're selling
something with a unique mechanism,
something that they've never experienced
ever before, like for me, one time I was
selling uh a new style of funnel and
that style of funnel didn't make sense
to most of the market because most
people were used to ClickFunnels and
Russell Brunson stuff and blah blah
blah. I equated it to like doing a pour
over coffee. Hey, sometimes when you,
you know, set up a coffee, because my
audience is very used to it, you'll pour
the water up top, the water will go
through a specific style of filter. So
that way when you get to the bottom of
the coffee, it actually tastes good.
That's how you get qualified leads. It's
got to go through a specific filter. I
did it by equating it to coffee. He's
doing it by equating it to a bridge,
right? Hey, keyman risk is what happens
is if you have a bridge, you're
explaining it with a picture. You're
it's called linking. Joe Sugarman calls
this linking. You want to actually link
your idea to something they're already
very familiar with. So that way when you
explain your new idea, it attaches to an
old concept that makes a lot of sense
already for them. And he's doing a
really good job with the visuals and
things like that too, right? Like all
the animations, they come in the middle,
they fall apart. So he's doing he's
doing what's called linking and he's
doing it really well
>> and dies, right? Not great. And so how
do you know if you actually have key
risk? So I know this because when I'm
trying to sell my company, gym launch, I
was the key man. And
>> okay, so this is now he's actually
opening up. So it looks like earlier he
started the story loop. So he opened a
loop. This is what happened when I was
in the business. And now he's telling
the story to close that loop. Really
smart. Open a story loop early on, pivot
somewhere else to keep explaining the
framework, and then come back to close
that story loop. And so for any
potential acquirer like a private equity
firm or institutional buyer, having one
person, especially the owner, who's
going to leave is a massive red flag.
And so they're thinking like, we're
buying this business, but removing the
one person that makes this thing work.
No way. Right? And even if it weren't a
massive red flag, it'll just
dramatically reduce the valuation of the
business. And so once I fixed this, I
was able to run my company off of one
meeting a week. Now, to be clear, that
didn't happen overnight. It took two
years to get from me being involved in
marketing, sales, ops,
>> okay? So I love what he's doing here. So
what he did was he told a story and then
he painted uh he painted a very quick
ideal picture where he said it ended up
with me being able to run this business
with one meeting a week. The people
watching this video would be like oh my
gosh if I could run my business with one
meeting a week. But when you say stuff
like that, people's BS meters start to
go off like crazy where they're like,
"No, no, this guy is full of crap.
There's no way he's doing this." And so
his credibility and his believability in
this is going down when you have a big
claim like that. But you see how he
immediately pivoted to the like now let
me be honest about this now it took me
two years and I had to do this and ops
and recruiting and sales that's called
uh making the skeleton dance. It's a
it's man I forgot who did Ben Settle
teaches it in so many of his books. He's
not the originator of it, but making the
skeleton dance is basically uh showing
the bad parts of your sales pitch really
honestly where he's like, "Hey, listen,
man. It took me like two years to figure
this out. I had to hire a bunch of
people in sales and blah blah blah." You
are showing the bad parts where you're
like, "Hey, it wasn't easy. It was
really hard." Right? You're telling
those things because it actually gives
you credibility and believability for
the thing you said just a second ago
where you're like, "Yeah, now my
business is down to one meeting a week
and I'm running a hund00 million
portfolio." So, he knew when he said a
big statement like that, he's going to
have to back it up with some
believability. And making the skeleton
dance is a great way to do that. Let's
keep going.
>> Critic all of it to me being able to
have an executive team that could take
the company, continue to grow, continue
to be profitable with just one hour.
Getting to that point resulted me
selling the company for $46.2 million.
And so today,
>> you see that credibility getting there
resulted in me selling the company for
$46.2 billion. I like how he cracks
credibility eggs all over this VSSL. So
in typical like sales pages, they a lot
of people hold the proof to the very
end. They like they make a big promise,
they introduce the mechanism, they tell
the story, and then they litter it with
all the proof at the very end. But you
may have lost your reader. You may have
watch lost your viewer by that point
where Alex is is cracking credibility
eggs all over his VSSL. He's injecting
things like, "Hey, I've taught this to a
thousand businesses. Hey, I got my uh
meetings down to an hour a week. Hey, I
sold my company for $46 million, right?
He's injecting those little credibility
eggs where it's like, man, this guy is
legit as he's pacing instead of doing a
bunch of proof at the end." I like that.
a on a portfolio of companies that last
year did over $250 million in aggregate
revenue and we implement these same
systems across software, local
businesses, e-commerce, consumer
services, professional services, home
services, medical services, probably a
business like
>> Yeah. So, what he's doing is he's
objective overcoming. He's not only just
doing proof, but he knows that he just
sent a whole bunch of different business
people to this website and the first
thing they're thinking is, "Yeah, but
it's not going to work for me." And he's
like, "No, it works for ecom. It works
for SAS. it works for local businesses,
brick and mortar, whatever. And he's
doing all of this stuff as like, dude,
I've done this across the board because
he's objective overcoming because he
made this big claim. He taught this big
framework. He's kind of cracked some
credibility eggs, but the this is to the
point in the VSSL, right? A little bit
more than halfway, 75%. Where people are
like, nah, it's not going to work for
me. So, he's starting to objective
overcome
>> yours. And so, fundamentally, if you
sell online via checkout, online over
the phone, in person with a salesperson,
selfch checkckout, there's the only four
ways you can sell stuff. If you sell in
any of those four ways, we have worked
with a business like yours many, many,
many times. And so key man risk presents
itself in four main areas. So number
one, marketing. So you're the only one
who knows how to get leads or there's
one. This is where he starts unpacking
his framework. So if you have a unique
mechanism where you're like, hey, I'm
teaching this framework, this key man
risk thing. He's starting to unpack his
unique mechanism to use it to he's
obviously he's going to inject his
service to solve the problem with this
unique mechanism but he's starting to
unpack it really you're smart to build
some more credibility
>> person the business who only knows how
to get leads and if that person left the
business is screwed the second is sales
which is that you're the only person who
can close leads and you may be this
person that only you trust with
>> I think one thing we should notice here
as well is this is a visual thing but
that like progress in the top where he's
like he's teaching one thing and then
the progress meter is filling to the
right. That keeps people watching
because it it gifies the video sales
letter for them, right? A little bit
harder to do obviously with the copy
unless you have like a progress bar up
top, but a progress bar is super sick on
salesletter, but he's obviously doing it
with the progress bar in the top right
as he's unpacking the four frameworks
because typically this actually may be
where you lose somebody where you're
like, "Hey, this is uh this is how it
works." So, it's it's in the marketing
and it's it's in the sales and the lead
process. And this honestly could be more
of a boring part. So, they probably have
AB tested that, hey, we get like 75% of
our drop off here. So, before they
actually get to the pitch and their pain
has been agitated, we have the
credibility and we start unpacking this
to actually buy more believability from
them, we start to lose them. So, let's
add a progress bar so they keep
watching.
>> Customers or that customers only trust
you. It doesn't really matter. At the
end of the day, there's only one person
who can close. The third is product or
delivery, right? You might be the the
one person who can figure out these
complex things or you're some super
genius or whatever, you know, thing that
you sell is, but that still makes you
the bottleneck to everything the
business delivers. And then finally is
fourth, which is the operations, right?
You're the only person who can hold
everything together. You're the glue.
You're the one that everyone respects
and that if you were gone, no one would
kind of keep the trains running on. One
thing that I think is really curious is
that he killed the music. I don't know
why he killed the music, but I think I I
think that's interesting that he did
that while he's explaining this stuff.
Maybe he'll bring it back. time. It
would leave a huge vacuum. So, here's
the wild part. The more valuable come
and this is something that was like
super painful for me because I'm such a
big like investor in self-education. But
the
>> he's relating himself to the audience.
This is something that was super painful
for me. I'm such a big investor. It was
really hard for me to do. He's relating
to the business owners.
>> More valuable you become, the more of a
keyman you become to your business. So,
it's this double-edged sword of the
better you get, the worse it is for the
business in a way, right? And so the
more places one person, specifically
maybe you, the keyman, exists, the
riskier the business becomes overall and
the less likely an acquirer is to buy
it. So here's
>> So he's he's taking this thing where
he's flipping the positives of you being
awesome. So it feels like a reverse
objection where somebody may be watching
this and they're like, well, I know this
and nobody else knows this and I can
handle this and I'm actually really good
at managing my business. and somebody
who may not think that they need this
product, which would be interesting if
they made it this far, who may not think
they need this product or they're seeing
the positive signs of like, man, maybe I
don't know. I don't think I'm that bad.
Some people who do this like lukewarm
purchasing thing where they're like,
"Ah, it's not too bad." He's doing this
thing where he's he's even flipping the
positives into a pain agitation. Hey,
it's a double-edged sword. You think
this is good? Do you think this is good?
But really, it's actually going to cause
a problem for you in the future, which
shows his superior knowledge of like,
hey, I've been there. I'm further than
you. I could take you along. Which is a
a Yoda move all day long. But I also
like how it actually pulls out the
people who have those like subtle
objections, right? They have these
subtle like I'm not so sure. They're the
they're the quiet lurkers. They're the
people who like really just kind of skim
through and then they X out because they
haven't been hooked yet. But when you
say like, hey, actually this is worse
than you think it is. Uh I I like that
because it pulls somebody in like that a
little bit further.
>> That's what I've learned. So as soon as
you learn the system too rapidly
removing keyman risk which you can do in
a repeatable way you can unlock the
ability to scale and fast.
>> Okay. So two things that he said here is
the system. Everything that he teaches
is almost always always always in a
system. That's because people want
systems. People love like four-step
systems a proven framework. They are
tired of guessing. Not only that they're
tired of Google searching and trying
different stuff. Everybody proves that
they have a specific framework, but he
starts with his system putting something
in a simplified system and then he goes
from system to benefit. Implement my
system equals scale and fast, right?
Because that's what everybody wants.
They want to scale and fast. So he knows
his target audience, right? And he's
repeating the benefit over and over and
over through a system, a framework, and
it's got a name. So that's always helped
sell more for him. And so I think about
it like this. Assembling companies and
assembling people and then transferring
skills around whatever area has a
bottleneck where too few people know how
to do the thing. And so whether you want
to sell your business or not, making a
business that's sellable makes it better
for everyone. So, business owners,
>> gosh, he just broadened up his market so
tremendously where he's basically like
even if you don't want to sell your
business because he's been harping on
that like it's investors can't buy it
and this happens and this happens and so
he just shrunk his market to people who
want to sell their businesses as opposed
to people who want to grow their
businesses. and he's saying, "Hey, even
if you don't want to sell your business,
you want to be sellable." Which I think
is super smart because what he's doing
specifically is he's not going after a
niche niche niche niche niche market.
Which I hate. I can't I I don't think
everybody should go after the most niche
market possible because then you're
going to end up with seven customers,
right? Or seven people in your target
audience. He's going after such a broad
market of people, which I think is okay
if you know how to pull the stops and
the holds on stuff like this. So, what
he's doing was he knows he dug himself
into a hole. He might be niching too far
with the problems and the agitations of,
"Hey, this might not be relative anymore
to these people." And he's digging
himself out of that hole and saying,
"So, even if you don't want to do this,
you want to do this because it's going
to make you infinitely more valuable
even if you keep your business." that
want to scale and potentially just have
the option for an exit all have one
thing in common. They are the bridge.
And then they ask a similarly worded
question. How do I stop being the
bridge? Or how do I stop being the
bottleneck? How do I
>> I'm glad he did the how do I stop being
the bottleneck because when he tied it
from how do I stop being the bridge to
his framework, people don't say that.
They don't say how do I stop being the
bridge. They actually say how do I stop
being the bottleneck. So interesting
that he actually caught himself do that.
>> Stop being the constraint. And so the
answer is well it depends on where you
experience command risk. And the good
news is though it doesn't matter which
of the four that I mentioned it is there
is a system to solve it and I know
>> that so okay so this is a very long
problem agitation solution sales letter
because he agitated for a long time and
this is where he's he's pivoting into
the solution. You could tell and this is
why and this is where uh which is why
he's doing statements like that that
bridge him from the agitation. Hey, I'm
not going to teach anymore. I'm not
going to unpack this concept. I'm
actually going to deliver it like this
and then I'm going to unload it for you.
>> Know it because I've lived it. And so
that's why we ended up creating the
scaling workshop. It's a way for us to
meet companies help them get through
these exact problems where they're
currently at in their industry and their
size. Business owners fly to our
headquarters in Vegas to work with our
team hands-on over a two-day sprint to
help them implement the system.
>> I think this is so underrated when
people actually start to explain that
like, hey, this is how it works.
business owners. You will fly out to our
headquarters in Las Vegas, very specific
location, and hang out with my team for
two days. Very specific deliverable. Not
enough people actually start to unpack
the solution. We're going to help you do
this, and we're going to help you do
that. And it's so vague that by the time
you get to the solution area, people
should be hungry to say, "Oh man, this
would be awesome. I would love to do
that." And then you people start
peppering this vague stuff where he's
being really specific. I love that. But
>> here's the thing. This is not a room,
you know, like a big conference or big
rah event where you, you know, sit in
the back and you take a bunch of notes,
you know, or something like that. We
work with a maximum of 100 businesses a
time. I think the average is around
80ish.
>> Oh, I love that. The urgency, the
limitation. You want to give some sort
of urgency to your ads. So now, now he's
in selling mode. He works he works with
a maximum of a hundred businesses. He's
running millions of dollars of ads to
this. Let's see if he doubles down on
that. But he's adding urgency and
limitation to the end of this VSSL
>> and there's zero motivational talks. You
like read all the reviews we have
online. They're like zero hype, no BS.
If anything, people are like this is a
lot. But that's the reality. Like if
there was one match,
>> I love that he's also going into like,
man, you can read all these reviews. So
again, he's cracking other credibility
eggs and he's overcoming objectives
while he's selling. People are just
like, oh man, I don't want to go to
another conference, a big rahrh. I don't
want to get a bunch of this or that.
He's like, it's not this, it's not that,
it's not this, it's not that. really
really good
>> magic bullet that would actually get you
to solve a business. Everyone would do
it and it would only read magic bullets.
This is what everyone would do. And so
there's a process a sequence of steps
that you can follow what some people
call a system to getting from point A to
point.
>> He is doubled downing on this system.
This is how much people love systems. If
you solve a problem for people and it's
not in a system, your VSSL, your sales
letter will do significantly worse than
if it was in a system. You have to get
that
>> point B. And so we will work directly on
your business with your specific
challenges and so that you can leave
with your complete three to fivestep
execution plan with owners timelines and
everything built specifically to your
business. It's extremely tactical. So
people love tactical. Everybody loves
tactical. I know like strategy and
philosophy has like been a hype where
like everybody's got to do strategy blah
blah blah. No matter what you sell in
any niche, if you try and sell somebody
with something strategic or
philosophical and it's not tactical, it
will sell far less. It will just sell
infinitely less than anything that was
like, "Hey, I'm going to teach you how
to write great email copy as opposed to
here's seven email templates." Seven
email templates is so much more tactical
than I'm gonna teach you how to write
email copy. People will take the
tactical over the strategical any day of
the week and thrice on Sundays. And
that's exactly what he's double downing
like. You're not going to get a bunch of
theory and and a bunch of like talking
and strategy and then you got to go
figure out how to actually apply it to
your business. He's saying, I'm selling
the tactical.
>> Imagine this. Instead of being the
bridge that everything depends on, your
business runs on systems, right? And you
can step away for a week or a month and
the revenue continues to flow. And you
have a team that makes decisions with
value. Clients will get served the same
quality and growth is predictable.
>> So now he's painting the picture of the
future. So he did all the pain,
agitation, solution. He introduced the
solution and he's painting the picture
of the future. This is a good format for
a VSSL, right? Pain, agitate, introduce
the solution. Paint a dream of what it
looks like to have your solution. Put
them in the picture. He's actually
painting a picture of them in the
solution where he's like, "Man, you're
actually going to be able to take a
vacation without having to be on your
phone all the time. You're going to be
able to do this. You're going to be able
to do this." And so now the person
watching this and the person reading
this is seeing themselves with that
product with the benefit of that
product. They see themselves in future
pacing of already buying this. This is
the end goal here. So you're no longer
trapped in a highpaying job. You
actually own a true business that works
for you, not because of you. Now I can't
promise that the rainbows are going to
come and unicorns are going to, you
know, carry off in the distance because
it works on you, right? But we can't
show you how we do it and how we've done
it with our portfolio companies across.
>> Oh, I love that line. So, I can't
promise this. I can't because the work's
on you. This is a tactic that Ben Settle
calls sell by repel. So, you want to
repel the people who would want like the
unicorns and the blah blah blah. Oh my
god, I'm so excited. Even if they pay
you money, these are going to be the
worst customers ever. And so, what he's
doing is he's pre-reppelling those
people. sell by repel, which actually
makes the right people more attracted to
you and the wrong people less attracted
to you because they're like, "Oh my
gosh, this guy can't guarantee me
anything without a guarantee. I'm not
going to buy anything." You know, you
get those NPCs and you just don't want
to deal with it. But the right people
are like, "Yeah, of course, of course
you can't promise that. Of course you
can't promise that." Those are the right
people. And so he's selling by repelling
>> across all these different industries,
across all these different sizes. And so
every day that you remain the keyman,
you are not building the business.
You're building a very comfortable
prison, which sucks, right? I get it
because I've done it for a very long
time. And hey,
>> God, he is coming back on that pain.
I've never seen like like he's already
introduced the promise and he's like,
"Hey, I just want to anchor how bad this
is." That is so interesting.
>> To be clear, if you want to just
continue to work that way, it's totally
cool. Like I am king of like do whatever
you want, right? But as long as you
>> All right, that like Hey, listen. if you
want to do this. This goes back to like
the Gary Halper in his emails and
letters or just his letters. He would
end stuff with like, hey, whether you
buy this or you don't buy this, I don't
care. I'm eating steak tonight either
way. Basically, like he would inject
this non- neediness at the bottom of his
sales letters where he's like, "Listen,
I don't care if you buy this." And that
non- neediness is so attractive. Can cuz
you know the like the car salesman like
you get on the car lot and they're like,
"Hey, would you like to buy this Buick?
It's like it's a half off and it's got
these steel doors and you're and you're
just like, "Oh, it's gross." You're just
so needy. Like you like you need to sell
this to me. And and he's injecting like,
"Hey, I told you my pro I told you the
system. I told you the problem that I
solved. I told you the solution to it. I
told you where it is. I told you all
these things. Listen, I don't care if
you buy. All right? Like you do whatever
you want to do, boo boo." Right? Like he
just he auras this non- neediness. So
good.
>> Understand that's what you're getting
into. The thing is the people who come
out to Vegas to one of our workshops
tend to be the ones who want to turn
those kind of like high-paying jobs into
assets. They want to create something.
They want to build something that's
separate from themselves, something that
is sellable if they so chose to. The
reality of this is that there's never
going to be a perfect time. In fact,
these problems typically compound. They
get wor
>> overcoming the objection again. Oh, it's
not a perfect time. Blah blah blah. It's
very interesting that he doesn't do this
in order, right? cuz it's not writing,
which I always think is different about
a VSSL where there has to be pacing,
there has to be entertainment, there has
to be like interweaving and so he's
still overcoming objections even towards
the end of this. So, I like that. I like
that he's cracking credibility eggs
throughout it, right? He's weaving it
like peaks and valleys and then he's
cracking like overcoming objections
based on what somebody would would say
at that point of the sales page.
>> That's usually when they're not
addressed quickly. might be feeling that
right now. And so when you book a call,
you can reserve a priority ticket. Even
if you need a little time to pick the
exact date. It's one of the number one
reasons people are like, "I'm not sure
if I should book caught out. Book call
now. Let's get a fit. We'll see. Make
sure they
>> Yeah. So it looks like he's got a little
bit of friction in his sales page, which
I really like. Like you can't just buy
um because what he actually wants to do
is he wants to continue selling you. All
right. So he knows that, hey, this thing
is going to cost 50 grand, whatever the
ticket is. It's something like that.
It's like 50 grand. So he knows people
are not just going to check out and put
a deposit or anything. Hey, just book a
call. even if you're like a little timid
about it, don't worry, we're going to
talk to you. And basically, he means
like I'm going to sell you, right? Like
we're going to get you on the phone
because he knows he's going to have to
have a sales team to close this thing.
So, you have to figure out what's the
right amount of friction for somebody to
take the next step in your product. Um,
and you can insert that amount of
friction. A lot of people are timid to
insert friction. We're like, "Oh, no,
no, we don't want to do this." Like, we
don't want to have another point in them
for that. No, you have to have the the
gradual next step. can't take somebody
from VSSL to putting a $50,000 deposit
on. Just like if I were to, you know, do
an ad campaign on meta ads and I was
running meta ads to to join my email
list. I'm not going to run meta ads to
go buy my $500 course. I'm going to run
meta ads to go buy my $10 tripwire and
then my $10 tripwire will sell them my
$500 course. I want them to buy
something, then I'll buy a bigger thing.
He's doing the thing. I want you to do
something and then I'll ask you for the
bigger thing because a lot of people
will do a leap way too big. They'll leap
all the way over here and they're like,
"Okay, now buy my big mega course." And
they're like, "No, no, you no, I don't
trust you." Right? So, he's doing a
small leap to a bigger leap.
>> And it works both ways. And then we'll
just make sure that there's a time that
fits within your calendar. All right?
And that way you don't get stuck waiting
another 6 to 12 months while these
problems continue to get worse. Done the
right way. The crazy thing is it's like,
"Hey, you know, my foot hurts. Once I go
to see the doctor, it's like, well, when
my foot hurts even less, it's like,
yeah, but reality, it's like it's gonna
be even harder to walk in the future.
And so sometimes the best day to fix a
problem is today. The problem.
>> So it he's hitting this like time for
urgency right now where he's like, "Hey,
I want you to book a call today."
Because this is the point where people
start making a decision. He's creating
the urgency by increasing the pain. A
lot of people create more urgency by
like, "I was curious if he was going to
do it like, man, there's limited spots
and blah blah blah." But he's doing it
by focusing on their pain, which is
really, really good because the whole
limited spots, hey, there's only 80 to
100 people and we don't know when it's
going to book out and then blah blah
blah and this and we're never going to
run this workshop again. And that stuff
just comes off so sleazy that people are
like, man, this guy's full of crap. He's
doing a really good job of creating the
urgency by actually increasing the pain,
which is a great emotional way to create
the urgency without having to do time
bonuses or anything like that. He's
like, I'm focusing on you, the buyer,
not me, and my crap and my offer and my
deadlines and my fictitious things like
that. You create urgency by increasing
pain.
>> Problems do get worse. And so many
owners do come to us in the middle of a
very busy season. And that's totally
fine because if you can learn how to fix
the business in a busy season, then
it'll be a breeze during an easy season.
No matter where you're at, whether it's
an easy season, a middle season, or a
busy season, and I've yet to meet a
business owner who says it's an easy
season, will structure your plan so it
actually fits your
>> great relatability. Just another line
that's like, "Dude, I've been there. I
know that later.
>> All right. And so the key is deciding to
fix it, not waiting for the kind of like
the mythical unicorn perfect moment
because that we all
>> he's saying the key is deciding to fix
it to book a call. So he's now he's
selling the next step, not the big big
workshop. So he was selling the big big
workshop as the solution. Now he's just
selling you on the next step. Hey, I
just need you to do the very small next
thing, which is really really smart.
>> Oh no. Never comes. And so if you want
to get our team's help, our actual
directors who actually do this in our
portfolio companies in our company, go
ahead book call with my team. We'll see
if it's a fit. And if it is, can't wait
to meet you.
>> And if it is, great to be. So, he's
ending it right there where this is a
great VSSL, by the way. Absolutely
wonderful. He's ending it right there
with the absolute next step. I'm I'm
assuming if I go, I'm ready to scale.
Yeah, exactly. It's book a call. I'm
going to put my name in. You got to fill
out the form, blah, blah, blah. All this
stuff. Really, really awesome. We're not
going to break down the whole page. We
just want to break down the VSSL. But
overall, I thought this was a great
VSSL. I loved breaking it down. I hope
you got a ton of nuggets from this one.
I hope you enjoy videos like this. Uh,
if so, leave a comment down below and
let me know what VSSL you want me to
break down next, sales letter you want
me to break down. I will do all that for
you. I'll help you out. In fact, before
you go, I've got some free stuff for you
as well. Copywriting Catalyst, which is
my 63 cash cow copywriting guide to give
you a bunch of free wisdom on how to
write better copy fast. Takes you about
60 seconds each to read those tips. and
101 super sticky hooks. That's going to
help you write hooks that are uh they're
definitely really good that you can put
at the top of your VSSLs um for your
target audience, all that stuff. A bunch
of templates in there, very tactical,
very easy to use. Grab both of those
resources. I'll do some more breakdowns
in the future. Again, I'm Alan Dragoo.
Super excited uh for you to watch this.
I appreciate it and I'll catch you on
the next